ciao ogni anno ragazzi come sapete credo
tutti faccio il log di quando vado
all'e3 di los angeles che è questa fiera
enorme di videogiochi e quindi va da una
settimana a los angeles tutti gli anni
perché ormai è d'acqua fissa ogni volta
blog tutto quello che succede
ed eccovi il blog di quest'anno di los
angeles
buona visione la maghetta ma che cazzo
no è una cosa più bella della vita
da un minuto siamo atterrati c'è donald
trump che balla da ragazzino finalmente
s'è fatto una foto era fatta siamo
finalmente atterrati a los angeles sono
con lui e di mio hayter numero 1 grazie
la mia accompagnato in questo viaggio
incredibile siamo arrivati in hotel
c'è mia moglie che sta provando ad
aprire la porta ma non ci riesce vai
tesoro aprire la nostra stanza d'albergo
che siamo in viaggio di nozze mamba
tesoro ti serve una mano dal tuo uomo
faccio vedere come funziona quando porta
guardano è un problema porcava che mi
sono pagato già è vero che spesso mi
piace aspetta farlo fuori anche a me e
sul mio letto
apri apri apri fammi vedere fa vedere
kakà mi sono cagato addosso anno ma
questa è per te tesoro ahia ahia ahia
ma che cazzo no dai non l'hai fatto
davvero non l'hai fatto davvero ma amore
amore qua c'è un ferro da stiro amore
qua un ferro da stiro non ho paura di
usarlo tesa luca lucano a bussare
[Musica]
perché avete messo la musica sulla mia
musica
io di te scusa è stata una reazione in
condizioni sono incastrate come cazzo
hai fatto il castanese dire perché ti
senti ma non ti ho fatto non l'ha fatto
apposta ma visto che le tre inizia
domani stiamo andando a farci una
passeggiata a malibu dal nome mali
musica non sacrifica la canzone nuova di
miley cyrus yamamay libri base ma il
bisogno di vento per le views le news e
manca nessuno che conosca sarebbe mai in
grado di fare questo marchio mediazione
distaccato alla sedile biancardi del
trofeo come hai fatto a staccare il
poggiatesta del sedile di antonio
[Musica]
la bellezza di fare blog in quattro e
che poi tutti i luoghi sono uguali per
tutti lo chiama la stessa cosa però sti
cazzi siamo arrivati a malibu in questo
mi sono arrivati a malibu in questo
momento questa è la spiaggia di malibu
porca vacca
sai quante foto tumblr vengono li ami
uno sponsor e allo zaino come si deve
rivedere grande aspetta e metto lo
aspetta aspetta di palla che metto la
sigla di baywatch
[Musica]
beppe
si no sarà questo un pokémon antonio mi
fai una squadra da serie in camera anzi
sexy che mi serve per la sigla di
baywatch fi grazie poi ammesso ma melo
dopo bere ma neanche blood il vampiro
che questa roba
e succo di rapa già goccia è invisibile
è una roba veramente obrobriosa ma la
beviamo perché raccontano di stefano
ieri oggi è bravo amico tanti auguri
stefano sarà salute
questo modo che schifo come non c'è
vegas quindi in genere guida lui quando
siamo così come non c'e lega sono le
venuto los angeles
oggi qui da sasha
siamo nella merda dai che facciamo le
views se moria in autostrada nonché
ragazzi ci teniamo a dirti che non siamo
per niente preoccupati di come guida
sasha
per niente preoccupati bye bye per le
views perquisisce lo per le views
consentirà fare un manganello conti sul
col manganello perquisirlo dai questo
cappello non lo puoi portare il 2017
picchiano ragazzi sono i bambini gli
otto anni e poi ci siamo noi che
facciamo le giostre bravo blogging se
hai
[Musica]
come un po dopo i bambini urlanti
finalmente ci siamo noi che facciamo le
montagne russe
ciao ma lo senti che scambierà tassa
sicuri
[Musica]
porca vacca è stato bruttissimo però
l'ha fatto anche più di fi pagò
colonizzato anche ma li vuole sociali
bugie
[Musica]
grazie per avermi portato qui
allora ragazzi venuti a santa monica
però mi sono mi sono mi sono mi sono
risvolti nato fino al ginocchio sono di
che cosa stai bloggando no che per
questa finisce su youtube piacerebbe su
vimeo mi sono stirato i pantaloni fino
al ginocchio come come ips che le chiede
dovuto fare questa cosa fa veramente
troppo capito che passati si passò con
un fischietto dark però fa veramente
caldo mini per oggi vanno bene i
risvolti di salvo salvo lo facciamo
anche noi
vado vado a destra e fa sei pronto
e proprio una giornata incredibile per
aver scelto di vestirsi con la felpa
ecco i pantaloni lunghi ma vaffan
ok ragazzi ma per andare a testare la
freddezza dell'acqua dell'oceano che non
mi ricordo io sono testata maila proceno
però è fredda proviamo a vedere se
veramente breve so già che io come tocco
l'acqua mi misi fredda anche il cervello
che non ho mai usato per ora
java bagnasciuga e freddo attenzione
devi dire devi dire anche jack che se no
non era il ha adesso capisco cosa
provava rose quella [ __ ] fa veramente
freddo ma tu ti saresti spostato sulla
zattera sei proprio un se proprio un hub
a cascia vuole che rimorchiano qui dura
ma mi riconoscono no no no non puoi
chiedermi aiuto a santa monica
ho fatto la foto con l'anima e sicuri
volevamo farlo anche con aspetta aspetta
che ti spiego quanto me ne sta fregando
stando a quanto è ambigua sta situazione
lo dico è fatta era quello no amore non
era nessuno
sì ho finito i compiti delle vacanze
mi ha promosso col 56
ok basta quindi ragazzi questo era più o
meno il cazzeggio che c'è stato a los
angeles e adesso arriva la parte dove
c'è appunto le tre la fiera che questo
tipo questo mega games week
non so come spiegarlo la seconda parte
di lobby los angeles e la faccia la
settimana prossima il faccio solo vedere
come partita la cosa per farvi capire
che c'è dell'ignoranza anche per le tre
guarda che modello che ho scelto e
modello che modello che ho scelto per il
mio zaino devo scegliere chiunque
mariano di vaio se lo offerto mariano
arriva invece no c'è lui fa targhette in
ferro riserve a darmela in testa perché
intanto ha incassato l 3 quest'anno è
affollatissimo e siamo riusciti
fortunatamente a riservarci un posto
sull'autobus per il quale abbiamo
lottato un sacco e siamo riusciti a
sederci perché tutta la gente che viene
con noi si è svegliata molto prima per
prendere il posto sono stati più
fortunati a sederci grazie a dio che
aveva portato a mio zaino a los angeles
la prima cosa che gli fanno un ispezione
anti bomba perché effettivamente uno
zaino con la scritta bravi j
va può sembrare il sospetto e quindi
controlliamo noi non ci sia il tritolo
dentro a questi ragazzi che sarà la
prima volta che facevo vedere il mio
zaino il caso fa parte sempre la linea
scuola che uscirà quest'anno come l'anno
scorso solo che quest'anno è molto più
[ __ ] perché l'ho fatta io però va tipo
anche questo ciò che poi appunto per
farvela vedere l'italia strada perché mi
hanno detto aspetta che quindi ragazzi
spero che mi sia piaciuto e continuerà
nel prossimo dove ci sarà appunto le tre
fatemi sapere ragazzi siete noi vi è
piaciuto e cosa è giocare nel momento e
mi piace anche a vari social comunista
descrizione se non sapessi dispiace ci
vediamo un pò signorino belle ragazze
[Musica]